I say that I drink twice a week when
it's raining and when it's not raining
my name is Rizzo Tahoe I've born here in
Munich arrived and I make the best
Cocozza in Brazil casa is a liqueur made
from one hundred percent sugar cane
sugar cane I would say this gives energy
for cars with ethanol if you give energy
for the body with sugar and it gives
happiness with cash option for all the
people charging so it's very good it has
a honey-like quality to it but it
doesn't taste hot doesn't taste
alcoholic beverage is running my blood
because I drink all the drinks in the
world and I love drinking mots as a
drunkard but I I love their ribs strong
OG Kush assa is the main ingredient in
Brazil's national cocktail the
caipirinha last year the country
exported 9 million liters of picasa
valued at about 16 million dollars
Mexico exports almost 20 times as much
tequila producers like Luis Ottavio hope
the world cup puts casazza on the map
many people for the first time are going
to taste cocozza here and I think all of
them they'll like you can prepare with
the best tequila the best Scotch whisky
and the best cognac historically
Brazilians considered casa a low-class
drink it had an image problem in America
too until 2012 the u.s. classified casa
as Brazilian rum to make a run you have
to boil the sugar cane juice you make
the molasses and you hydrate the mail as
you you let it ferment for keshava you
go up the pure sugar cane juice and you
ferment the sugar cane juice directly
and when it's fermented you have about
twelve percent of all now the u.s.
recognizes casa as a distinct spirit in
return Brazil agreed to recognize
American bourbon and tennessee whiskey I
went to me
bored many times and I saw their the
process of Jack Daniels and I try to
apply to the Bolivian cashes it improve
it a lot the flavor de smoothness is one
of our sellers is where we age the cash
shot I raised a very careful here long
time before it's no good business
dealing with milk kasha is death